So working with native
elements is great for
focus behavior,
because they're automatically inserted
into the tab order based on
their position in the DOM.
To give you an example I've
written a little bit of HTML here.
I've got three button elements and
then you can see the output
over here on the right.
So there's three button elements
rendering inside of my browser.
Now because the tab order corresponds
to the DOM order, when I go and
press the tab key you'll see
that the first button element
gets the focus indicator around it.
And as I keep pressing tab, you'll see
the next item in the DOM order gets
focused and tab again, now the last
item in the DOM order is focused.
Now it's important note that
using something like CSS,
it's possible to have things
appear in one order on screen, but
actually exist in a different
order over in the DOM.
To give you an example of that,
what I've done now is I've just
added this inline style to
my first button element and
I'm telling it that I want
to float to the right.
Now what this is going to do is it's
going to visually change the ordering of
these buttons here such that our
first DOM element is now appearing
last on screen visually.
So even though the visual order has
changed, the DOM order remains the same.
Let's see how that effects tabbing.
When I press the tab key, the first
DOM element is still focused, but
now visually it's the last element in
this group which is kind of weird.
If I press tab again,
now we see that the second DOM element,
which is the first visual
element becomes focused.
And pressing tab again, I've got this
middle element now being focused,
even though that's the last DOM item.
So the moral of the story is, be careful
when you're using something like CSS to
visually change the position
of your elements on screen.
This can cause the tab order to
jump around seemingly at random and
for users relying on a keyboard
this can be extremely confusing.
For this reason the WebAIM checklist
specifically states in section 1.3.2
that the reading and navigation
order as determined by code order
should be logical and
intuitive in your application.
I have just sort of
a general rule of thumb.
I like to tab through my page every so
often just to make sure I haven't
accidentally messed up the tab order.
It's a good habit to adopt and
it's one that doesn't really
require a ton of effort on my part.